the thing about transformers is you're
watching just literally just robots and
robots fighting robots
yeah and it's it's like what's the point
of just it's just to see some cool
effects and this one it's like why are
you fighting here why are you doing
earth you just go to your own planet or
another why thank the Allspark somewhere
else and fight gars where there's no one
walking around you don't have to destroy
New York City oh yeah and why do the
Decepticons would want to take over the
[ __ ] earth like what the [ __ ] do you
mean you don't have to offer the worship
it's better than all our [ __ ] like you
can really just here to destroy our
planning for no [ __ ] yeah but hi I'm
Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry welcome two
reasons to see when we give you reasons
to see and not to see Pacific Rim Sur
tonight we are canceling the apocalypse
and and doing a movie review
Rory's in a/c number one
insane robots vs. monster [ __ ] yeah this
[ __ ] is literally insane like you're
watching it and it's [ __ ] awesome
yeah it's pretty crazy it's like some of
the craziest action I've seen in a long
time it's totally unique though the
physics behind the actual like machines
you could feel the hips of these just
shot in science-fiction CG going on but
like you can feel the impact of it it's
totally effective and it's so cool to
watch I think a lot of people are
comparing it to like transformers
especially I think it tops transformers
by far this is worlds different from
transformers and you could easily make
that comparison but yeah I mean watching
these these big-ass robots fight these
giant monsters there is something that
feels totally different and completely
more awesome and more easeful applause
yeah it's yeah yours you know giant
robots and kaiju giant monsters and yeah
there's some there's there's something
more organic to it I feel than
transformers like everything as former's
has sort of a sheen and sort of but it's
like they're just as effects-heavy but
this one feels like there's more
humanity in it but Pacific Rim you guys
inside of the machines they're operating
them in a it's like they're communicated
through the mind that you know drift
compatible I think we'd be drift
compatible we could be drift competitive
anything so just so we hop into our
minds and this just in mind this is for
sex yes maybe now you're really horny
man no maybe I wish I wasn't in your
mind right oh wow you got a lot of [ __ ]
in him I didn't need that the fighting
feels different and it's not so much
like transformers it almost feels like
after a while it's like ah my brain is
turning into liquid because there's so
much action and in this movie there is a
lot of action but it all feels like it's
built in a proper way like it escalates
and there are dynamics to it it's not
all the same like well there's emotional
effect that's action
occurring in this film you know
especially because you care you can't
enough about the people that are inside
of these machines and at the same time
to the monsters look scary there are
really good effects on the monsters and
they have there all different kinds and
and it's it's just insanity to be honest
that's what's so cool is that it keeps
escalating and there are different
robots in different different types of
gadgets - yeah yes so everything is very
interesting and very detailed and stuff
like that and it's because like you know
like when the humans are inside of the
machines they gotta like instruct the
machines on how to do stuff and they got
to do the movements yourself
so you you actually feel like you're
part of the action in a way you know
rather than just watching like observing
robots fighting each other you know
that's a lot of people comparing this to
Power Rangers to like the very adult
version of the operators and you know
what's the problem with that sounds
[ __ ] I love a dark take of Power
Rangers sounds awesome that what and
that's part of what is so so great about
this movie is that it does hark back to
all those things like Godzilla and Power
Rangers and you know and even to an
extent transformers and you know like
the cartoons and stuff like that it's
I've heard it described this way by a
bunch of people it's sort of everything
you loved while you were 12 you know
everything that was just like oh that's
incredible like I'm gonna movie for this
stuff and it's awesome it's like it's a
nostalgia that way so it's you know what
I just really appreciate this movie is
that when you watch the trailer do you
want it you see that you're like Dane
that all looks awesome yes and you know
you're watching you're like it's even
awesomer than the trailer yeah because
it does more stuff than just robots
fighting months yeah yeah exactly it's
creative too and it's slow motion
well yeah you also get the physics of
like these things are huge so it's not
gonna be like a super fast punch it's
like we need rockets to propel the punch
yeah exactly
so elbow rocket yes yeah that's pretty
rad sword Oh Mike ain't no a first time
I thought there were some kills where
the audience was just applauding and
there's major destruction there is your
destruction yeah one of the best
destruction rip you know this year is
all about [ __ ] up the world yeah and
[ __ ] up the world really well but it's
not like you know I love manage steel
that's not like Matt have still run like
man if these two people would just find
a location is a fight a lot of people
would not be dying but in this one it's
like no man these are giant yeah you had
no choice but to fight in the cities and
stuff at any time you can use a
battleship like a ship as a baseball so
awesome
all the effects in this are so cool just
the designs of the whole futuristic
world it's immersive it is like looking
into like the near distant future boy
yeah it's kind of got a little bit of a
strong feel sort of but at the same time
it's got its own unique spin on it all
of the costumes were so all the designs
were just so [ __ ] awesome look at all
the jaegers look different they all have
their own design and they're all sort of
tailored to the country they're from and
that all the kaiju are different and
they have that sort of Guillermo del
Toro creature Flair yes with things you
would have seen in a Godzilla movie so
it's it's really cool designs and the
effects just the way everything looks is
mind-blowing it's one of those rare
visual feast movies that is mainly
you're gonna go for the visuals that you
actually walked out going I feel like I
got a lot out of it I've seen so many
movies that are just visual thrills that
I don't enjoy but this one I was like
it's worth it just for the action the
visual effects I saw this twice on IMAX
I'm not gonna tell you the perfect seat
I know the perfect seat and you know
what man that [ __ ] is [ __ ] insane if
you haven't seen it on IMAX
you have to watch it on IMAX just once
at least are you gonna be selling on a
regular screen and you hated it watching
on IMAX your opinion might change
because this scope of like the machines
and stuff you can feel the scope it's
like really looking at giant fish it's
insanity yeah and what's crazy effects
looks super [ __ ] real too at the same
time it's a it's totally believable
breathes in the sea number three the
directing and cinematography every gear
about that's where our movie has awesome
directing and an awesome cinematography
your mandatory and Guillermo Navarro
yeah have you to get every single
imagery the lighting complements the
effects so well the direction of it it's
not kinetic craziness throughout the
camera takes its time you know there's
some handheld shots in there one a
little
yeah what and the way it's captured
really communicates the scope of
everything it really makes this world
feel larger-than-life you make it me you
really get the gravity of how big the
kind you are and how big the jaegers are
and how much destruction is going on
like it's the way is captured is great
this is like totally del Toro's movie
you know and I'm like it like you
brought it up to me when we saw it like
it is like it's the comparison of Kill
Bill for Tarantino like this is a maje
movie to like monster flicks and yeah
and stuff like that and it totally is
you know and after I have you told me
that I was like it really is like Del
Toro's personal homage to a lot of these
things in a way yeah that's a man is
lettin is in their 12 year old out you
know to bring all that stuff he loves
and you can feel that love while you're
watching and you can feel that
enthusiasm and that and honestly the 3d
to like I haven't seen on a regular
stream but on IMAX some of the best 3d
I've ever seen
without a doubt like it really looks
like [ __ ] is coming at she won't like it
just from the opening shots like you
know what [ __ ] the fish look like
they're swimming reason to see number
four a dress Elba he's my favorite
performer in this film
he's a total badass you know it's cool
to see a British major in the film you
know and he is right here I think could
be a real star turning performance for
the guy he's got that leadership edge
you know without being too corny about
it you know it's just the right amount
of tough leader and while still getting
the idea of the movie I think this is
great line that he hasn't it
or it's like you don't know my past and
I'm not gonna tell you my whole life
story
mmm but when he says that you're like I
could tell hitters ala came up with this
whole past reason is see number five the
school
skarner this is cool it even the score
has a little bit of a throwback live it
like it's rock and roll kind of music it
what you know and that's another that's
another sort of sign I could tell they
must have had fun making this because
the score changes and it is always the
right thing for the right moment so when
you know there's a big showdown in the
middle of the city it's like yeah let's
bring out that rock guitar we want to
see these guys kick some monster yes you
know and then when it's a little more
serious and it's a little more serious
and then there's even some stuff that
feels like it was sort of out of a
Godzilla movie the movie just wants you
to have fun and it takes itself
seriously enough to yeah at the same
time reason to see number six Rinko
Kikuchi I really like this girl a lot
she was cool like she's a really cool
character I thought if someone gives the
best performance with my favorite
character I thought was her actual that
stuff they do with her character there's
some emotional stuff there's some badass
stuff there's some stuff that you really
feel for her she's a good actress she's
a really good actor and I mean they they
would be remiss if they didn't have
somebody Japanese in a leading part of
this really I think they owe this movie
owes so much to Japanese cinema yeah
yeah it's even got kind of like a Gundam
Wing filled the same time yeah there's
all sorts of stuff in there and and she
does a great job
oh there's just really good scene where
she's to go to the testing out the
Jaeger she doesn't even say anything but
it she doesn't she does an excellent
[ __ ] job number seven Charlie Day
Rain Man he's fun to watch in this movie
you know like there's a lot of scenes
where he's you know it's basically he
has to operate the scene and he is
really fun to watch and this film
perfectly cast yeah Charlie Day is gonna
be a Pacific Rim I was like huh
interesting
yeah yeah I'm a big It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia fan I loved him in Horrible
Bosses and then I see him in this I'm
like this guy he's really making his way
up the ladder yeah he's proving he can
do like roles where he can be taken even
a little bit more serious because he's
one of the comic relief kind of
character in a way but at the same time
he
like a joke character he's got the
comedian of the film it happen oh yeah
and that's another thing about this this
film generally is of heard the word
cartoons running around and I think that
does fit because there is a certain
level of sort of cartoon enthusiasm to
some of this stuff so exactly it's like
Charlie Day isn't hey cracking jokes
what has wanted the board heightened
characters he's in a very important
character to like yeah you know I like
it so he's saying to Philadelphia he's
like the stupidest one of the characters
yeah and this one he's like the smartest
one of the characters that you totally
buy him as this guy there is even a
moment where you know he got me a little
misty-eyed oh man Charlie yeah reason to
see number eight Ron Perlman Robert
Maillet he doesn't have a lot of screen
time in this movie they show him on the
trailer and I was like I must have a
little small role but he's a scene
stealer like no the few scenes yeah he's
a delight to watch yeah really cool how
much fun it's classic Ron Perlman you
know like tough guy with already the
same time he's kind of funny and stuff
yeah you know like he's got the keys
still got his charisma even though he's
kind of a dick exactly him and Charlie
they have a couple of scenes together
and they play off each other pretty well
yeah I mean he's another one of the one
of the more colorful characters in this
movie and one more he's sort of out of
their heightened Giessen and he does a
great job though look and then and his
whole getup and and everything about his
characterization is just so much fun to
watch what decisions doesn't mean it's
character potential okay here's the
thing
I really like a lot of the performances
in this movie but when I look at the
foundation of the characters that they
laid out and everything because the
prologue is great and they set up the
characters very well but as I watched
the film I noticed I didn't really care
a lot about the drama that was going on
and I realized that's because I didn't
care it as much for the characters as
this film was capable of allowing me to
care for these characters because a lot
of the talk you know it's about the
mission and moving on it's constantly
moving forward with the mission and
stuff like that which is fine but that I
could see that they were also striving
for some good character stuffs and I
thought the only missing element in this
awesome set of
there's like some real unique [ __ ]
characters even if it's like throwback
characters they I thought they could've
amplified it still just a little bit
more I get I mean I can see where you're
coming from it didn't really bother me
in this movie though because I felt like
again it is sort of a throwback and it
is a throwback to those archetypes and I
thought that was fine
because you know it's sync it also see
that point though yeah at the same time
yeah because it's a big you know it's a
big adventure
I felt like cared enough about the drama
like everything grabbed me just the
right way and I mean it could be deeper
but it's like you take a movie like
Avatar and that's a movie that people
criticized for being you know all the
characters are black and white it's good
guy evil guy you have the gamut of
archetypes you know all these characters
we've seen 100 million times before and
why it doesn't work for that movie for
me at least is because that movie is
taking itself real serious where this
movie is like it's supposed to be I get
the sense it's supposed to be sort of
cartoony and heightened and it's
supposed to be just fun and a throwback
and so those archetypes to me work in
that environment but just when I was
watching and I it's one of those things
where I was like potential is there and
I get upset not upset but I get a little
letdown when I feel like potential is
not met I mean it's people comparing
this to like how quits and Tarantino's
Kill Bill was to him like that omage but
like people watch Kill Bill for like the
action the blood all that hell of fun
stuff but there's also an awesome
[ __ ] set of unique characters and I
thought like this film had the
capability of doing that but at the same
time I could see where you're coming
from on that and you know a lot of
people are reacting differently to this
movie like just depending on who you are
but everyone has their own
interpretation that's cool to kind of
get from a summer blockbuster that you
weren't expecting now a bunch of
different types of interpretations of
what they thought was good because a lot
of people love the characterization in
this movie and then there are a lot of
people were like the characterization
sucks and but you also gotta think about
it you look at the characters and
they've all got these you know crazy
names and stuff like that and they're
all sort of heightened no longer has
called Hercules yeah there's a guy
yes get a Hannibal Chau yeah is who Ron
Perlman would so you know it's like I
get the sense that these are all
supposed to be sort of outlandish you
know cartoony types and a little less I
thought the characters that got a little
more deep was fitting and all the ones
that were just a little more in the
immediate part of the situation were
just as good so i had minor issues of
the lead character like a lot of people
really criticizing this guy's
performance and i didn't hate the guy's
performance in order to dislike it i
thought he did an okay job but i thought
for a lead character he could have been
a lot more interesting to watch he could
have a man that was another thing to
where i got used to the the acting style
of this movie because it took me a few
minutes and i realized i get the sense
that everything is supposed to be a
little bit heightened and i thought that
Charlie Hunnam played that role he
played that archetype again it's like he
played that guy that you know
square-jawed like I'm gonna you know I
don't play by the rules but I'm still
gonna get it done you know that's fine I
I really just gave her lunch of monsters
and robots kick some ass come here to
see this it's but there's no safe even
though I was kind of let down by by not
beating up its potential I still feel
that like hey what you're going to go
watch this movie for it definitely
delivers on that yeah exactly it's like
if you found yourself in the theater I
have a feeling that you'll get what you
came for
yeah exactly and my only other complaint
deal with the characters is uh
the other scientists character the guy
isn't that Dark Knight Rises who is the
assistant to Daggett he's apparently
British and he I think uses a stomach I
like a fake accent annoying because he
was so car I thought it was a little too
cartoony like the movie was too humorous
or too cartoony enough to have him be
that animated like it distracted me I
was like this is like a character from a
different film I guess I can see where
you're coming from but I had so much fun
watching it and I felt like you know
when you meet those two K you meet
heaven you meet Charlie Day and Charlie
Day is a little more animated than a lot
of the other characters
met so far and then burn gorman is more
animated than him so it made it a nice
little stepping ladder for me and I just
I had so much fun watching him Brian's
good sunsets insane action and effects
thrills is the reason to see Pacific Rim
seen action and effects thrills is the
reason to see Pacific Rim like we keep
saying everything you want to see in
this [ __ ] movie it delivers Jerry's
Consensus badass robots crazy monsters
and childlike aw is the reason to see
Pacific Rim badass robots crazy monsters
and childlike are the reason to see
Pacific room yeah yeah I just had so
much fun being 12 again you know it's
like robots and monsters and scientists
and crazy Chinatown looking thing like
it's one of those movies where you're
like it's it's weird watching giant
robots and [ __ ] you're like I wish I had
like a buddy that I could drift with in
a Jaeger yeah like some [ __ ] logs
you're just wanna go out and be a robot
and fight stuff and yeah in the rain and
[ __ ] yeah oh my god it's cool all those
all right fans of our show thanks for
checking out our review
for Pacific Rim why don't you go ahead
school that comment box below and tell
us what is your favorite monster movie
or giant robot movie which is only one
other franchise and now once you're done
telling us all that stuff come over here
and click on this link to watch more
episodes the reasons to see and if you
want to follow us on Facebook you can
click the link right here and if you
want to follow us on Twitter you can
click the link right here and last but
not least if you want to get updated
every time a new review or video is out
subscribe
okay what is your favorite Jaeger in
this movie tell us below yeah yeah yeah
and click on all these [ __ ] links
right here
Bam Bam Bam Bam do it do it they don't
open up in a new window either to take
you right to that pace you're gonna have
to click back yeah you know what you
know what else is cool is that I gotta
give props to Travis Beacham who wrote
this cuz it cuz cuz it's you know it's
monsters vs. robots but they found a way
to make those fights escalate and get
different every time surprisingly so
it's not like transformers where it's
like okay we're just gonna watch the
same fight happen to bunch of times yeah
like three and a half [ __ ] hours yeah
it's like this one it's like wow you
really went a lot of places in this
thing up you know it escalates so props
props there's like there's some good
problems maybe - yeah dude that part
were these like typing on stuff and
they're like think of all the grass yeah
but yeah holograms yeah I love the
blasts hand
oh yeah that's like giant you know what
it is the machines look like giant
Master Chief's yeah it's like Iron Man
in giant master combined at the same
time I kinda but then there's some funky
looking Yeager's at some times well I
could yeah get Cherno alpha like I said
it's the Russian one the head sort of
looks like a nuclear reactor yeah it
kind of looks like a lost in space robot
fans in the top and I'm like oh such
great deep yeah there's a lot of great
detail they're really thought about like
how if they if we made these how would
they operate yeah and and what would
each country's look like I hope you
subscribed at this point yeah cuz we're
just look use the word ooh this is for
hots missus yeah we're just talking for
ourselves we don't need this footage but
yeah we're doing it anyway witty banter
ya know wasn't even that witty though
that was just
chosen a master we were agreeing on yeah
we were just kind of talking mm-hm is
going all along edit
you